Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test--
the steel sheet stab
and brass rod chop.
To test the strength
of your tips,
as well as all your edges,
I'm going to be stabbing
and chopping at these targets.
Remember, this test
is all about what
these targets do to
your daggers and not
what your daggers do to them.
Dorian, you're up first.
You ready?
You break it, you buy it.
I don't have that much money.
[clang]
Well, Dorian, it
looks like your blade
got Superman punched right
after the ring of the bell, man.
However, that doesn't mean that
you're out of this competition.
Jarrod, Jimmy,
both of your blades
have to survive at least one
strike against our test media
in order for you to move
forward in this competition.
If one of you fails
on the first strike,
then we move into
a deliberation.
So there's still
a chance, Dorian.
Good luck, gentlemen.
Ben.
[exhales]
Well, Jarrod, you survived.
Your blade here is substantial.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Jimmy, you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[exhales]
Well, Jimmy, your tip
held up beautifully.
I can't even tell that it
went through a piece of steel.
Nice job.
It's really a testament
to the heat treat
you did on this blade here.
OK.
Dorian, unfortunately,
your blade suffered
a catastrophic failure.
You cannot move
forward with testing.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitors' hands,
and then exit the forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
Good job, Dorian.
Thank you, sir.
I'm definitely bummed
that all my work just kind
of went down the drain.
Thanks for all the hard work.
It was an honor.
I knew I had a soft
spot in my blade.
You know, I did rush
the heat treat process.
When you have that
clock going, there's
those little details that
will come back and bite you.
And that's what happened
today during testing.
Jarrod, Jimmy,
congratulations.
You guys have made it to
the third and final round
of this competition.
Now it's time to shake
it down to your bones,
as we send you back to your home
forges to make one of these--
the horseman's tabar
with a hidden dagger.
I've never had to make
anything with something
hidden in the handle before.
So I have no idea how I'm
going to put this together.
At the end of your
four days, you'll
return to present your tabars
to a panel of expert judges.
And after they've
tested them, they'll
declare one of you the
"Forged in Fire" champion,
who walks out of here
with a check for 10 grand.
Do your best work, and
we'll see you in four days.
Good luck, gentlemen.
Good luck, buddy.
Jarrod, Jimmy, welcome
back to the Forge.
You guys have had four days
to work on your tabars.
Jarrod, how'd it go for you?
Easy, smooth, worked
out how I wanted.
I did a one-piece
construction head
out of some 5160 spring steel.
The handle is schedule
80 oil field pipe.
Dagger blade's made
out of schedule 160.
All right, Jimmy, tell
the judges about your blade.
The head's made out of
drive axle out of my truck.
Bottom was made out of the
trailer hinge ball off of it.
And I decided, since
we were doing all
that, I'd go ahead and
make the dagger out
of a piece of spring out of it.
Gentlemen, now it's time to
figure out which one of you
in our "Forged in
Fire" champion.
The judges will put your
blades through a series
of three tests.
There will be a strength
test, a sharpness test.
And up first--
Doug.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Your tabars and hidden
daggers look beautiful,
but it's time to find
out how lethal they are.
To find that out, I
will take your weapon
and deliver some lethal
blows to this big carcass.
Jarrod, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Oh, I'm ready.
All right, let's do this.
[rock music]
Messed it up, dude.
That was awesome.
You killed it.
All right, Jarrod, your
axe head here is very sharp.
It really digs
into this carcass.
The dagger, it felt good to
use it as a punch dagger.
It penetrated deeply.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
[bleep] yeah, it'll kill.
This is awesome!
All right, Jimmy,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Let her rip.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
Oh, my god.
All right, Jimmy, let's
talk about your tabar here.
Your axe head is sharp.
It penetrated very
deep into this carcass.
Now, your dagger, it feels good
in the hand as a punch dagger.
More importantly, it will kill.
Bladesmiths, welcome to the
strength test-- the armored
warrior stab and chop.
Remember, this test
is all about what
happens to your tabar
and your hidden dagger
and not what happens
to the warrior.
Jarrod, you're up first.
You ready?
Get her done.
[rock music]
Well, Jarrod, you made
a nice-looking axe here.
There's one little chip right
here, but the rest of it
is still pretty sharp.
All in all, I think
you did a great job.
Thanks, sir.
All right, Jimmy,
you're up next.
You ready for this?
I was.
[laughs]
[rock music]
[exhales]
Well, Jimmy, your edge
held up really well here.
There's no rolls or chips.
But there was one swing where
the axe twisted in my hand,
and I think that's
to do with the fact
that the oval
handle here is just
out of alignment with the head.
It's about five degrees off.
But in all, your axe held up
well in the strength test.
Nice job.
All right,
bladesmiths, this is
the sharpness test--
the sugar cane
chop and the leather vest stab.
Jarrod, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
All right, Jarrod,
your edge is sharp.
Also, in stabbing,
it punctured all
the way through, not an issue.
Overall, sir, the edge
of your weapons will cut.
All right, Jimmy,
your turn, sir.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
All right, Jimmy.
The one thing I noticed is
the way this is wrapped.
It's twisted a little bit,
and it rotates in my hand.
But it's sharp.
Also, your dagger
here does puncture.
And overall, it will cut.
Jarrod, Jimmy, our new
"Forged in Fire" champion is--
Jarrod.
Congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Jimmy, please
surrender your blade.
JIMMY: It's kind of bittersweet.
Jarrod, I'm glad for him.
But at the same time, you
know, it would've been
nice to bring home the victory.
It was challenging.
Good job.
I'm proud of you.
And it's real pressure.
But I had a blast here.
This was a great time,
just the whole experience.
Jarrod, you are the new
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
[applause]
How are you feeling right now?
Feels great.
Hey, man, a man
of thousand words.
Please present your
weapon to the judges.
I just won "Forged in Fire."
Yeah, I'm pretty excited.
Planning on buying a house--
[laughs] as soon
as I find a house,
and I can buy it with $10,000.
Probably not, but-- [chuckles]
[rock music]